you know in the 1970s Milton Friedman
The Economist theorized theorized that
the responsibility of business was to
maximize profit within the bounds of the
law no mention of Ethics you know and
that definition which was just a theory
was embraced by a class of leader
corporate leader in the day and they
used it to justify new behaviors in
business so for example the concept of
mass layoffs to balance the books um
which is normal you know CEOs very
comfortably go on TV and say we missed
our numbers we're having a round of
layoffs like you're profitable just not
as profitable as you promised um so
normal like they just do it very openly
that did not exist as a behavior did not
exist prior to the 1980s didn't exist
you only had layoffs for existential
reasons and so as American capitalism
became bastardized the rest of the world
started copying American capitalism
because it made a lot of money right so
now that American capitalism of
short-termism and rank and yank and all
this nonsense
has now spread outside the borders to
the detriment of global economies I
would add this is not Adam Smith
capitalism that made America great this
is a new version of capitalism which is
extremely short termist and extremely
broken and the result is we're seeing a
rise against capitalism there is there
is a a populist movement of foot in the
United States whether it's Bernie
Sanders or Donald Trump left and right
whether it's hungry or brexit or all of
these things they're all populist
movements against capitalism now they're
confusing capitalism and this version of
capitalism we want to reform capitalism
not eliminate it it's a good system but
it's very
broken uh the the decline of the middle
class and the stock market all of these
things the violation of the social
contract of leaders all of it all of it
um and I think that's contributed to the
lack of Honor that's why you have to do
a really good job you go to a program
like this to learn uh the a kind of
leadership that is different than the
80s and 90s models that that has become
normalized and standardized today so
that if you get it right and you build
the companies you work for in the manner
that they need to be built then we will
restore a belief in
capitalism or we will restore a belief
in trust and cooperation up and down the
chain of command where we trust our
leaders and our leaders trust us we will
restore a model where people will
happily give 10 20 30 years to one
company rather than one year one year
one year one year we will restore a
model where we derive tremendous Joy
from our work rather than tremendous
stress